- Welcome back y'all.
We've got Ashton Kutcher
here on this Valentine's Day.
(audience cheering)
Love is all around us.
We also have a room full of people
sharing their love for
someone in their life.
Everyone give it up for
Cynthia who's with her pup,
Butters, my favorite guest today.
Cynthia says, Butters isn't just her dog,
he's her soulmate and a joy to wake up to.
I bet, I would snuggle
so hard with Butters.
Butters is adorable.
Ashton's new movie is
called "Your Place or Mine."
It's a movie about love.
So to celebrate, it's time to
talk about the things we love.
This is...
Obsessions.
(sensual music)
(Kelly imitating sensual music)
- How it works is I hit this button...
'cause it's magical
and our supercomputer will
randomly select a topic
either Ashton or I are obsessed with.
- Okay.
- Then we have to really
sell our obsession,
and why it's great,
and why you should think it's great, too.
I'll go first.
- Got it.
- Okay, here we go.
(computer whirring)
- Obsession
- [Ashton] Obsession.
- [Kelly] Obsession.
It sounds weird.
I am obsessed with like with tiny homes.
And like, shipping containers
and making the homes.
Or they make pools out of them.
I'm obsessed because it's kind of like
renew, reuse, recycle,
and also it's like it
looks cool and modern,
but in like a rustic way.
You like it?
- Not only do I like it, I love it.
I actually had a dressing room
on Warner Brothers that I
brought in a shipping container
and turned it into a dressing room.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Oh, you know what you have to find?
You have to see this.
Okay, there's this thing
called Bumblebee Spaces.
And they basically put closets
and beds in the ceiling.
And then it's all on this,
like, machine-learning,
machine-vision that sees
what's inside the thing.
And so you could have a storage container
where the ceiling comes
out, the bed drops down.
And then you can be like,
"Oh, get me my blue T-shirt"
and then (imitating machine)
it drops it.
- This is so "Jetsons" right now.
- It's unbelievable for shipping homes.
- Bumble, bumble what?
- It's called Bumblebee Spaces.
Yes, you have to see this
inside your shipping container.
That's what you have to get.
And you'll be the happiest human on earth.
- I am, I go down the YouTube vortex.
I've seen all of them.
People are like, have you seen this one?
Like five times, I love them.
I think it's so crazy what people are-
they're just so innovative
with space and how they use it
and utilize it and the simplicity of it.
Anyway...
- And, Kelly...
if you need to move, you
just move the whole thing.
- No, but here's why, so I have-
- Just move the thing, move have house.
- I have a ranch.
And we had these shipping containers
with a lot of stuff in
it and then we're like,
we should use these.
You can move them to different
parts of the property
anytime you want.
- Yeah, you can.
- What Ashton? Yeah.
- Your turn.
Okay.
Ashton's turn.
- Obsession.
(bell dinging)
(computer whirring)
- [Computer] Obsession
(bell dinging)
- Wait, what?
- Orange juice in the coffee.
- I think you might be alone here.
- Okay. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
- Okay.
- I'm not big on creamers.
I don't like creamers.
I usually drink black coffee.
That is my go-to: black coffee.
- [Kelly] There's honey.
- I just like black coffee.
But occasionally I like
light roast black coffee.
And one of the things about
light roast black coffee
is that it has citrus notes in it.
And it's one of the things that make-
it's the acidity that sort
of gives it a brightness
when you're drinking coffee.
- Okay.
- And so it doesn't get
that burnt sense about it.
So if I ever have like a medium
roast coffee and I'm like,
ah, I really would prefer
this be a little bit more
light roast, I take just
a splash, not very much,
a splash of orange juice-
- I'm gonna try this.
- And it brightens up the coffee
and gives it a little bit of sweetness.
- I'm gonna try this.
I don't like a bunch of
stuff in mine either.
- Just a splash, don't go overboard.
If you go overboard, it
gets all sorts of not fun.
- Yeah, it sounds gross,
but I'm gonna try it.
- Give it a go.
- Yeah.
(computer whirring)
- Obsession
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay, first of all, I love a board game.
Secondly, I love "Codenames,"
but I don't know if I'm
the most fun to play with.
- Wait, hold on.
You have to get code names in-
Oh, just having code names?
- No, it's like a game and
there's all these cards
and they have words on 'em.
You're only allowed to use
a certain amount of words,
to describe...
So you're trying to
get your team to guess-
- To guess what the thing is.
- Yes, and I well, I just...
I like to call it passion.
I get very passionate
and I'm like, "Why aren't you guessing?"
Because I feel like I'm
giving a really great clue
'cause you can only use one word
and you have to try and get
as many cards as you want.
So let's say you have
cloud, forest, purple.
You're trying to do all these things.
- I'm just saying...
So we should play.
- Ah... lumber.
- Lumber.
- Lumber? Nice.
Purple lumber.
No, but I'm just saying I'm
obsessed with "Codenames."
Does anybody play "Codenames?"
Have you ever played "Codenames?"
(audience clapping faintly)
Okay, I love "Codenames."
- [Ashton] I'm sold, I gotta check it out.
- Okay.
- We love games in our-
- Have a little orange juice and coffee
while we're doing it.
- Little bit of OJ n' coffee
inside of our little
storage container home.
We're livin' it up.
- Awesome.
We're creating a great world here.
Okay, your last one.
This is yours.
- Obsession.
(bell dinging)
(computer whirring)
(sensual music)
(Kelly imitating sensual music)
(bell dinging)
- Oh, this is mine.
- River Rose... no, it is mine.
And the magical lullaby.
- I was wondering why
this was sitting out.
- Okay, hold on.
This book that you wrote,
I have read to my daughter
maybe a hundred times.
- Are you serious?
- So we read to our
kids every single night.
- 20 to 30 minutes every single
night that has to happen.
And so I've read this book so many times
but there's a thing in this
book that I'm very curious about
that I have to understand.
- Okay.
- There's a song in it, okay?
- Yep.
I've never heard this song.
So I have my version of how the song goes
that I just sing, my version.
So I would like to try to sing my version
of how this song goes.
- [Kelly] I can't wait.
- And then hear how your version
of the song actually goes.
- I'm gonna send your
your daughter the doll
that has me singing it.
- Okay.
Oh, maybe not because if mine is so off,
she's gonna be like, "Dad, it was not-
you haven't been doing it right."
- Just say there's different versions.
- Okay, so wait.
♪ Every night you lie with me ♪
♪ When I wake, you're still here ♪
♪ I don't know if ever I could find ♪
♪ Someone as kind and dear ♪
- Get it.
♪ No one gets me like you do ♪
(orchestral music)
- Whoa, what's going on?
There's no orchestra in my child's room.
We don't have an orchestra pit.
Hold on.
♪ No one gets me like you do ♪
♪ You can tell by my smile ♪
♪ I'm gonna miss you so
much while you sleep ♪
♪ But now I'm by your side ♪
Is that even close?
(Kelly laughing)
Was that even like remotely-?
(audience cheering)
And then I go like this.
And then this is what I do every night.
I sing it and then I
go, "How'd I do Kelly?"
(Kelly laughing)
Did I do okay?
Was that all right?
Was that befitting of
the tune that you wrote?
- Befitting of?
Yours was more like a real...
mine was more like a lullaby
and yours is more like a real song melody.
- Mine was a lullaby!
- Well, yours feels like a real song.
- Under that
♪ No one gets me ♪
That part gets a little too-?
- Yeah, it sounds like-
(Ashton imitates singing)
(Kelly laughing)
- It's a little different.
I'm gonna send you the doll.
- No, I wanna hear how it actually goes.
We all wanna hear how it actually-
- Okay, I do need the words.
I haven't sang this in forever.
My daughter now asks for a different book
with her name on it.
Okay, it's um...
♪ Every night you lie with me ♪
♪ When I wake, you're still here ♪
♪ I don't know if I ever a could find ♪
♪ Someone as kind and dear ♪
♪ No one gets me like you do ♪
♪ You can tell by my smile ♪
♪ I'm gonna miss you so
much while you sleep ♪
♪ But know that I'm by your side ♪
It's like a lullaby-
- Okay.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Don't you think?
A little different.
- Give me that back.
What, what? This is-
Hold on.
Wyatt, I'm really sorry.
I apologize.
I've never sang you that
version and I never will.
I can promise you.
- This is the best thing.
I should have done this when I put it out.
Like, come up with your own melody.
I should have done that.
That was a great marketing idea
because everybody probably
does come up with their own.
'Cause there were only so many dolls.
- There's no notes in here.
- We did not have staff paper.
- These notes are not on bars.
They're just kinda
flowing around in space.
- I know, but I think
what you did is special.
It's a special version.
I think that's sweet.
I think it's so cool.
I feel like most dudes I
know would've been like,
"and then there's a
song" and skip the page.
Yeah, you were going for
the merit badge on that one.
You got it.
You got the merit badge.
I thought it was really good.
(audience applauding)
And those, those are our obsessions.
- [Computer] Obsessions.
- [Ashton] Obsessions.
You're getting dirtier by the minute.
Like, "oob-session."
- Ooob-session.
- It's a-
- Oooob-session.
- A great daytime show.